[Musica]
buon pomeriggio a tutti io non so se il
fenomeno di cui vi sto per parlare un
fenomeno diffuso o condivisibile ma a me
è successo che fino all'età di 30 anni
ero pieno di risposte o risposte su
tutto e su qualsiasi argomento e domande
molto poche poi dopo i 40 ma soprattutto
dopo 50 sapete quell'età in cui si
scopre che si può non invecchiare ma
diventare vintage
ecco in quel periodo che poi il vintage
e uno stato ipnotico no in cui per
esempio anche io con le mie fattezze c'è
una mediana tra lo zio fester eno
sperato si crede io mi credo bruce
willis perché sono vintage quindi in
quell'età in quell'epoca
a me è successo totalmente il contrario
cioè di avere una valanga di domande e
quasi nessuna risposta due domande in
particolare che sollecitano il mono
neurone che vi contraddistingue sono la
prima è ci deve essere qualcosa
qualsiasi cosa che praticata ogni giorno
ci fa sentire migliori la seconda è
perché cosa verrà ricordato
ecco queste le domande trovano difficile
risposta ma diciamo che un responso mi è
venuto in aiuto un facile responso è
stato quello di dire la qualità delle
relazioni già le relazioni relazioni
sono la sostanza stessa dell'uomo siamo
fatti di queste ma in relazione poi sono
a 360 gradi cioè interessa non soltanto
e relazioni umane ma tutto quello con
cui noi veniamo in contatto durante la
nostra vita io la vedo un po come una
ragnatela no questo network la ragnatela
in cui noi siamo lì dentro che abbiamo
la straordinaria opportunità come uomini
con il nostro libero arbitrio di poter
essere a ragnatela o di rimanerne
imbrigliati ecco io in questa ragnatela
ho cercato di mettere tutte queste
relazioni vento una formula proprio
perché dotato di mono neurone dentro una
forma dentro un modello e questo modello
e l'ho chiamato tu ti unc puc e che
significa questo acronimo partiamo dalla
t
tempo le relazioni con il tempo passato
presente futuro
tutto ciò che ci lega alla nostra vita
ecco questa relazione ci insegna che il
tempo va impiegato e non passato perché
se il tempo non trova motivi validi per
restare fugge e tu o e umanità
quindi tutte relazioni che o no che o
non soltanto con gli altri ma anche con
me stesso sono relazioni fondamentali
quasi mai ci si trova d'accordo con se
stessi
ecco anche qui abbiamo una straordinaria
in quanto uomini opportunità di poter
scegliere perché noi siamo architetti di
queste relazioni e possiamo scegliere se
costruire muri più o meno grandi o
costruire ponti la n
la n natura la natura e la nostra mamma
e la nostra figlia quindi è la relazione
più importante più passionale che noi
possiamo avere nella nostra vita e la
natura soprattutto in questo periodo che
ormai da tanti anni ci fa nascere tante
domande tantissime domande e mi piace
sottolineare alcune per esempio quelle
proferite da una poetessa sudanese che
si chiama eli mo mahmood
che è anche un ambasciatrice di vn hcr
cioè dell'agenzia onu per i rifugiati
lei dice se la terra potesse parlare
cosa ci direbbe c ringrazierebbe c
applaudirebbe o 5 ore rebbe ea fine
arriviamo alla fine di questa formula
tour con l'aci la c è cambiamento le
relazioni con il cambiamento che sono
l'abbiamo sentito l'anima del nostro
sviluppo
l'accettazione del cambiamento dire
crescita si cresce soltanto con la
differenza e qui mi piace ricordare
toffler che dice gli analfabeti del non
saranno quelli che non sanno leggere o
scrivere ma quelli che non sanno
imparare disimparare e imparare di nuovo
allora questo tour io me lo sono preso
meno sono usato applicandola tutte
quelle che sono le situazioni personali
e professionali che ho vissuto nella
vita e diciamo che una prima risposta a
una mia domanda è arrivata soltanto
applicandolo negli anni per esempio alla
risposta a domanda perché cosa verremo
ricordati
io penso che noi verremo ricordati tutti
per quanto futuro saremo riusciti a
creare quanti metri di futuro quanto i
km futuro noi saremo riusciti a creare
come dei ciclisti positivi questo sarà
quello per cui noi verremo valutati
centimetro dopo centimetro
come diceva al pacino in ogni maledetta
domenica o anche cicciolina ma quello è
un altro discorso
allora io ho preso questo tunc che non è
teoria e pratica e pratica proprio vera
e operativa e voglio condividerla con
voi velocemente brevemente in
un'esperienza di vita professionale che
ho vissuto negli ultimi dieci anni dieci
anni fa io mi sono unito hanno un
azienda come amministratore delegato
un'azienda che contava più di 500
dipendenti quindi un grande netto a una
grande relazione con tante famiglie che
vivevano con questa azienda un'azienda
che purtroppo
versava in una crisi drammatica in una
crisi tremenda i numeri e la crisi
velocemente che vi do sono questa
azienda aveva un fatturato
diciamo aveva dei debiti che erano una
volta e mezzo il fatturato ogni mese
perdeva 2 milioni di euro
diciamo che è una situazione
difficilmente
recuperabile attraverso dei processi
normali pensate che ha come una famiglia
in cui entrano 10 mila euro all'anno ma
un debito di 15.000 restituire e ogni
mese ne perde mille
ora in questa situazione
la cosa peggiore quale era e che questa
azienda aveva perso tutte le sue
relazioni
la produzione non aveva più una
relazione con il mercato e con i
consumatori
la crisi finanziaria devastante a cui
era stata soggetta aveva deturpato
l'immagine di questa azienda
all'esterno e aveva deturpato anche
quelli che erano i valori etici
dell'azienda stessa
le relazioni interpersonali pensate con
la famiglia che viveva in questa azienda
erano state ugualmente leva state
distrutte dalla paura dalla disperazione
dall'ansia dalla precarietà
allora in questa situazione abbiamo
capito con un team un po pazzo più che
ha illuminato o forse perché avevamo
veramente poco da perdere che dovevamo
costruire un ponte e buttare giù
tantissime muri
abbiamo voluto approcciare attraverso il
tour questa situazione in maniera
diversa cioè normalmente
dall'imprenditore schumpeteriano quelle
che andiamo a studiare ci dicono prima
di tutto la sostenibilità economica
poi quella sociale poi tutte le altre
noi abbiamo ribaltato tutto abbiamo
coniato un principio che poi abbiamo
seguito durante questi dieci anni che
far bene alle persone e all'ambiente
fa bene al business far bene alle
persone e all'ambiente
fa bene al business
quindi prima
noi vogliamo raggiungere la
sostenibilità sociale
poi è quella ambientale e abbiamo
pensato che quella economica e
finanziaria fosse una conseguenza delle
prime due eravamo un po naif
forse però andiamo a vedere i fatti i
numeri che sottendono questo tipo di
approccio
abbiamo iniziato alla sostenibilità
sociale come siamo andati a lavorare ea
ristrutturare tutti i team di lavoro in
ogni divisione in ogni reparto
in ogni processo l'abbiamo ristrutturati
come formando dei nuovi team se
vedessero con occhi nuovi nelle
situazioni vecchie le situazioni ormai
standardizzare quindi abbiamo formato
fisicamente abbiamo messo le persone con
un assegno o riti aziendale molto alta e
quindi da molto tempo che erano in
azienda con dei neoassunti dei giovani
questo perché vogliamo creare una
miscela in cui la capacità dei delle
persone di esperienza fosse unita
all'energia dei giovani e alla loro
voglia di cambiamento
ecco i giovani alle persone di
esperienza non hanno chiesto
l'esperienza hanno chiesto la capacità
hanno chiesto la determinazione di
sapere di poter fare i prodotti migliori
del mondo
l'esperienza non la volevano e
attenzione che a volte l'esperienza è un
peso è un retaggio una relazione con il
tempo che ci portiamo dietro
nietzsche diceva l'esperienza il nome
che gli uomini danno ai propri errori
questa miscela straordinaria che ha
messo insieme questi team è stata
esplosiva era un rischio potevamo
fermarci invece è stata esplosiva è
stata esplosiva la voglia di successo la
voglia di riscatto che ha portato a dei
numeri perché poi sono quelli che
parlano di una produzione che è
migliorata nella sua performance del 40
per cento negli anni a quel punto ci
siamo dedicati alla sostenibilità
ambientale che era già nel dna di questa
azienda che però l'azienda non aveva mai
comunicato attenzione questo errore di
tantissime aziende di tantissime società
soprattutto italiane fare le cose
migliori del mondo e raccontarsi e tra
di loro non farle sapere fuori dove
avrebbero un valore straordinario
allora noi abbiamo ripreso questa
tradizione è questa vocazione
dell'azienda e l'abbiamo estesa come
mettendo insieme delle azioni piccole
con delle grandi opere con dei grandi
investimenti
le azioni piccole amici miei sono quelle
che noi dobbiamo fare tutti i giorni le
trovate anche nel sacchetto
una doppia altezza non buttare la carta
per terra la sigaretta se c'è un cestino
perché la buttiamo per terra perché
perché buttiamolo involucro di una
merendina in mare perché
con questo approccio nella famiglia
dell'azienda e facendo sentire l'azienda
come casa propria e i colleghi come una
famiglia tutti i dipendenti hanno
iniziato a spegnere le luci prima di
andare a casa a spegnere il pc la
fotocopiatrice a non sprecare la carta a
non sporcare a sentirsi a casa propria a
fare gli stessi gesti
e pensate noi stiamo parlando un'azienda
che fattura decine di milioni di euro e
questi piccoli gesti sono stati
fondamentali come i grandi gesti che
abbiamo fatto tipo abbiamo elettrificato
al cento per cento la nostra produzione
è tutta elettrica
e le risorse
energetiche per
per supportare questa produzione
le abbiamo trovate tutte da energie
energia rinnovabile come abbiamo fatto
un'azione con legambiente nel 2012 per
cui abbiamo coperto quasi 40 mila metri
quadri di tetti della nostra azienda con
pannelli fotovoltaici
abbiamo messo in moto una centrale a
biomasse e via via tante altre azioni
questo insieme al fatto di rendere il
nostro materiale riciclabile al 100 per
cento come abbiamo fatto anche qui
prendendo la formula del nostro
materiale usando soltanto materie prime
non inquinanti biodegradabili e anche
che non fossero usate in altri ambiti
per esempio quello medico quindi non
andando a sottrarre ad altri ambiti
questo tipo di materie prime i risultati
quali sono stati vi riporto quelli che
sono stati i risultati ambientali di
questa grande azione fatta di piccoli e
grandi gesti allora la nostra azienda
oggi produce eto'o migliaia di
tonnellate di prodotto con emissioni di
co2 vicine allo zero il fit for
fiftyfive che per pronunciarlo ci vuole
non so di essere ventriloqui forse
questa legge sul clima che è stata
presentata che dice che praticamente il
2030 tutti gli stati europei dovrebbero
aver diminuito del 55 per cento le
emissioni di co2 che avevano nel 90 noi
l'abbiamo raggiunta otto anni fa ma non
solo questo abbiamo risparmiato con
tutte le azioni che abbiamo detto prima
su tutti i costi energetici
noi abbiamo risparmiato in dieci anni
per una stessa produzione quindi a
paritari tonnellate il 45 per cento di
energia elettrica che essendo un'azienda
energivora questo 45 per cento significa
poter alimentare un paese di 6 mila
abitanti
abbiamo risparmiato un terzo del nostro
gas che già era quantità ridottissime
che significa poter riscaldare
2600 abitazioni bene e la sostenibilità
economica perché eravamo partiti da lì
dal fatto che non stavamo in piedi è
stata una conseguenza ci sono voluti
dieci anni dieci lunghissimi anni
io sono rimasto solo con questa camicia
perché lo sudate veramente tutte ma
chiaramente io non sono solo una piccola
pedina perché è stato un team che era
convinto di questa cosa qua
che ha raggiunta sulla sostenibilità
economica come avendoli minuto i costi
energetici noi abbiamo abbassato tutti i
costi del che erano il nostro conto
economico e abbiamo raggiunto quello si
chiama break even poi il punto di
pareggio
avendo diminuito avendo migliorato la
produzione del nostro prodotto abbiamo
diminuito i costi perché la migliorata
la performance se prima facevamo mille
pezzi del nostro prodotto
ora le facciamo 5000 e quindi il costo
sia abbassato e siamo diventati più
competitivi
e poi
e poi abbiamo aumentato le vendite
tantissimo quasi del 100 per cento
perché quello che facevamo noi l'abbiamo
raccontato all'esterno ai nostri clienti
ai nostri consumatori
e abbiamo aperto la porta che abbiamo
detto noi stiamo facendo questo perché
crediamo in questo e non è naif questa
cosa qua perché i fatti numeri non sono
cose e i nostri interlocutori hanno
trovato una relazione una qualità di
questa relazione talmente forte da
sentire sicurezza affidabilità nei
confronti di questo interlocutore e
perché no leggerezza
leggerezza
quanto abbiamo bisogno di leggerezza
soprattutto in un periodo che non stiamo
vivendo la leggerezza attenzione che non
è superficialità è il contrario della
superficialità e leggerezza
la leggerezza noi l'abbiamo prodotta
abbiamo prodotto anche la leggerezza
come nel 2015
56 anni fa abbiamo prodotto un video
musicale in cui tutti i nostri
dipendenti hanno cantato una canzone
originale in azienda questa canzone si
chiama stand up che appunto significava
il fatto c'erano rialzati tutti insieme
eravamo credetemi orgogliosi di quello
che avevamo fatto
e la trovate anche su youtube nelle
migliori negozi di dischi e trovate solo
su youtube
e quindi adesso che succede
beh intanto succede che noi andremo a
produrre leggerezza anche il prossimo
anno perché c'è un'altra canzone che
abbiamo composto bellissima che
canteremo tutti in coro in azienda
insieme e uscirà adesso ai fans qui ci
stanno aspettando quindi scapperò per la
porta di servizio ma sono uscirà a breve
relazione qua e la cosa più importante è
che io ho trovato la risposta anche
all'altra mia domanda l'altra mia
domanda era cosa si può fare tutti i
giorni qualsiasi cosa per poterci
migliorare
per me la risposta è stata far bene alle
persone e far bene all'ambiente
perché questo significa avere la
relazione più bello cioè condividere la
relazione della felicità con tutti
e significa essere felici e soprattutto
sapere di essere essere felici e
soprattutto sapere di essere essere
felici e sapere di essere
[Applauso]
[Musica]